so we're counting down to the first
polls closing in New Hampshire tonight
we'll find out the results of the
nation's first state primary election
we've all been putting in a ton of work
preparing for the big event and after
Harold so generously helped me back at
the debate back in September if you
remember that I thought I could return
the favor for Jesse and obviously with
so much to do our day together started
at 5:00
a.m. hi everyone I'm so excited we're in
New Hampshire it's the day of the
primary and Jesse Waters came and so I
can help him get ready Jesse good
morning hello New Hampshire primary day
do you want hi
Jessie I've read these papers and I I I
marked some of the places for you no I
was out late with hemmer last night I
got to get some more sleep why don't you
take a look at these I got maybe take
two more of these cards just to look at
and then we'll be right outside and I'll
meet you there so a couple of books so
just help you for care goodbye okay okay
see you soon don't go back to sleep okay
can't wait want me to get you a coffee I
can get you some
coffee oh great you're ready okay
excellent we just have a few things that
we're try to get in it's been 15 minutes
how many books have you read just a just
just like five but I mean there it's
just it's not a lot are you always this
chipper in the morning yes but I'm
working on it okay does this place have
a gym I got to go do some cardio it does
it does you want to go together and we
can study while we work
out uh yeah sure come on let's do that
fine okay great let's go okay got it all
right we have a lot of material to study
I made it easier for you with some note
cards Dana do you really expect me to
memorize all these notes not really I
mean it's really not that many and I
just have a few more here so I
alphabetized all of the counties in New
Hampshire by population so you could get
started on memorizing that I had just
took the opportunity to write down the
breakdown of New Hampshire primary
results since 1920 read those memorize
them Carl Ro is not always going to be
there for you and also I surveyed 500
New Hampshire residents and I have notes
on what they think here Dana Dana I I
don't want to know too much I want to
feel I hear you I hear you but I just
just take these just a few more just to
get your make sure you're all set before
prime time we got to go over the rundown
for Prime Time by the way I'm so glad
you said that I have 100 ideas Prime
Time New Hampshire so exciting
okay okay this is interesting you'd make
changes to the rundown I don't think
that you can say that Michelle Obama is
going to replace Joe Biden on the ticket
Dana it's an option I don't really think
it's real though I think it's a fantasy
did you see the Cindy Adams oped I did
see this but I think we should get
another opinion I'm just looking out for
you tell you what why don't we call your
mom and see what she thinks do we have
to yeah let's call her I love Mom hey
Mom yeah yeah it's Dana she wants Waters
to talk to you hi so I'm just going
through Jesse's run down here in New
Hampshire Jesse wants to say that
Michelle Obama's running for president
obviously that's not happening so I just
want to protect him what do you think
I'd listen to Dana honey bun yeah right
all right Bye Mom bye I have a better
idea okay follow me where are we
[Music]
going now this is what I'm talking about
I don't know do you think we really have
time for this Dana the key to
preparation is
relaxation I don't know I have this
folder I could just you know maybe bu
osmosis get some more preparation in
before
tonight Dana just hold my hand and
breathe wait maybe you're right maybe we
do need to
relax Dana I'm always
right
and there you have it Jesse's always
right judge we ended at the
spa well I got to tell you it looks like
you had a very busy day preparing how
much work did you do
today we got a lot done I got a lot done
you always do I got a lot done Jesse
have you learned that you have to listen
to Dana not really uh I think
preparation's different depending on who
you are for instance I took an Uber back
from a walk and the guy was a fan and
told me about stoicism and I learned
more in that Uber ride back from my walk
than I probably would reading the Wall
Street Journal cover to cover yeah I'll
bet you could do that anywhere Jesse
Greg I wish you'd been here because I
would have woken you up and we would
have had you with us right there on the
elliptical yep in a
minute Greg do you like our acting I
thought it was fantastic I made a couple
of points then I want to address a
bigger story uh Dana on thep itical you
look like a toddler trying to cross
country
ski um I didn't realize how short I
would look the the best line of the
whole thing was Jesse citing the Cindy
Adams opad which kind of like a lot of
people missed but that just was that
might be one of the all-time great lines
did you read the Cindy Adams op head is
amazing but while you you're doing this
cute segment you're missing out on the
real story if you notice that Dean
Phillips is put put all of his money
into New Hampshire just as ronto santis
is pulling out of New Hampshire is this
a coincidence have you ever seen them
together look at them
doppelganger watch your mouth Dana
family
show Harold how do you think we did I
thought you guys were frankly
outstanding I was just glad you did not
trip like I tripped when I was trying to
take your bag into the uh in into the uh
the bait Hall there at the Reagan Center
and I was surprised I thought Jesse was
a 4:00 a.m. Riser so 5:00 a.m. you look
like you were Just Awaken brother what
was going on well it's called acting
Herold something you know nothing about
thank you I write that down too two days
in a row now you're you're on a rooll
that's all right and of course we
appreciate the participation of Jesse's
mom as always all right hi everyone I'm
Brian killme I want you to do me a favor
I want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now